-Come on. Welcome to the show.
You look fantastic.
-Thank you bud,
thank you, thank you.
I couldn't disappoint you.
-No, you never disappoint me.
Tell me about this, though.
You explain it a little bit
in "Relentless."
But congrats on the new book
here, "W1nning," first of all.
But you started --
You didn't start
as a trainer or you did?
-Well, here's the thing.
I did start as a trainer.
So when I went to college,
I didn't know what I wanted
to do, like everybody else.
So kinesiology
was just getting started.
-Your parents
were fine with this?
-No, they weren't, not at all.
-No.
-Both my parents
come from India.
-Okay.
-Alright?
So back in the '80s,
as a son of Indian parents,
you got two options
for a profession.
Doctor being one,
a doctor being the other.
[ Laughter ]
That's it.
I told them I wanted
to train professional athletes.
They goes,
"What does that even mean?"
-Yeah.
You get vacation time,
you get a two-week paycheck.
I said, no, I said, I'm going
to train professional athletes.
And, you know, behold,
everything I went through.
And it ended up happening.
-Yeah. And you just did it.
But then you get in there
and you have the opportunity
or you just said,
"I'm going to train
someone from the Bulls"?
-I was working
at a local health club.
I was making $3.35 an hour
back in the '80s.
That was my minimum wage.
I know yours was 7.50.
I did some homework on you now.
-Wow, yeah, I did. I got 7.50.
7.50.
-Yeah, yeah, I paid attention.
-I started as soon as
I could start working.
-That's exactly what I did.
You know, you sit --
you can't be sitting at home,
you finish school,
you're like, all right,
I've got to do something.
So I took a job at a local
health club,
stayed there
for about three years.
I saw a small article
in the newspaper.
It said Michael Jordan is tired
of taking a physical abuse
from the Detroit Pistons.
Hmm. Light-bulb moment.
So back then, remember,
no cellphones,
no texting, no nothing.
-No.
-Handwrote 14 letters.
15 players on the team.
Did not write to Michael Jordan.
He's the best. I've never worked
with a professional athlete.
-He'll never --
-Nah.
There's just no way.
He's not -- No way.
One person.
He found the letter
in somebody else's locker,
gave it to the athletic trainer
and said,
"Hey, find out
what this kid's about."
Lesson learned.
The best of the best always are
looking to get better.
Always looking to get better.
-This is you training
Michael Jordan.
-Yeah, with the mustache.
That's the only picture
you can find, huh?
[ Laughter ]
-You look great.
You look fantastic.
-That's the only picture
you can find.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But, I mean, this is
at his peak here with the Bulls.
What were these
training sessions like?
-Very, very intense.
Very intense.
It would be either 5 a.m.
in the morning, 6 a.m. or 7.
That was our time that we wanted
to get the workouts in,
and they were very intense
and I was doing stuff back --
we're talking about '89, '90.
I was doing back stuff where
people are just discovering now.
I mean, we did the crazy --
we did the craziest things.
I did stuff for his fingers.
I did stuff for his wrists.
I did stuff for his ankles.
-His fingers?
-Yes, because in basketball,
your fingers are constantly
jammed.
You have to have the dexterity.
You know, if you're
playing a piano,
that's how you control
the basketball.
So different things
that weren't taught in school,
but I just knew were right.
You know, you got
to trust your instincts.
You just got to know, hey,
this is the right way
to do things.
So, you know,
we'd have sometimes --
I would literally go home
after a game.
And this crowd may be
a little bit too young
to understand this,
but you had to record a game
on a machine called a Betamax.
[ Laughter ]
Anybody know what a Betamax is?
Alright.
-We'll explain
what a Betamax is.
Wow. On Beta?
-Betamax.
-You made that investment?
-Yes, I had to.
Yeah, it was a bad one.
[ Laughter ]
-It was the only investment,
bad one you made.
-Yeah, it was bad. It was bad.
-But I would go back home
and we'd be the last ones to
leave the stadium and so forth.
Because I never worked
for the Bulls.
I actually worked
directly for him.
So I'd go back home
and I would literally watch
the game over again.
Not for the highlights.
To count his steps.
-You actually counted how
many steps he took on the court?
-How much -- how many steps
he took left,
how many steps he took right,
how many times
he landed on one foot,
how many landed
on the other foot.
All these different things
because I was like, okay, well,
if one side is being used more
than the other, well, we can't
train them the same way.
We can't train them
the same way.
So I would hand him weights
and one hand
would be completely different
than the weights on the other.
The reps on one side would be
completely different
than the other,
just different things.
We did stuff for his eyes.
We created all kinds
of distractions.
Just stuff that I knew
that would work,
that would just work.
And he was open to it.
He was like open because
he was just like, "Man,
just -- I don't want to do
what everybody else is doing.
If I do what
everybody else is doing,
I'm going to be like
everybody else."
-Yeah. And he
just wanted to win.
He's like, "I'm going to."
-His obsession with winning.
-Yeah.
-He knew there was a price
that needed to pay for winning.
And he was -- Most people --
Everybody knows
you got to pay
a price for winning,
but most people
aren't willing to pay it.
They may pay it once,
but literally you got
to pay it every single day.
And the crazy part about that
is the price changes daily,
just like the stock market
goes up and down.
The price of winning changes
on a daily, daily basis.
And you got to be willing
to pay that price,
whatever it is on that day.
-Is that why,
like, all of your --
You make points, almost like a,
I don't want to
say it's a 10-step program
or something like that.
But usually you see the 10 steps
on becoming successful.
The 10 steps -- All of your
steps are named number one.
-Yes.
-Number one, do this.
Number one, do that.
Number one, do this.
Number one.
They're all number one.
-Right.
-Why?
-Not a typo.
-No.
So here's the thing.
With my ideas is --
and the audience can relate
to this -- when you get a list,
you see things one,
two, three, four.
People pay attention to one,
not as much to two, eight.
When you get down to 11, 12,
they're like,
eh, it doesn't matter.
-Yeah.
-It doesn't matter. If you
list everything as number one,
and I knew all of these
were equally as important.
But what was number one, what
was the most important thing,
what your number one may not be
somebody else's number one.
So you can take that list
and interchange it
to your definition
and your vision of winning
and your vision
of relentlessness, take it
and just like,
hey, you know what?
Today I need this
to be my number one.
-Yeah.
-But that doesn't mean
this -- doesn't mean
discount the other stuff.
-I was so inspired
by "Relentless."
I loved it so much.
Do you have people
coming up to you
and saying like, "Wow, this book
changed my life"?
-I have people coming to me
all the time to say
"the book changed my life" and,
you know what I do is,
I didn't -- the book
didn't change your life.
You changed your life. The book
just gave you permission.
It gave you permission.
You know what "Relentless" did
to a lot of individuals?
It gave them -- They understood
they're not alone.
They were not alone,
that this mentality --
Everyone thought, "Man,
I thought it was the only one.
I thought I was the only one."
And when they read the book,
they were like, "Wow,
there's a lot of us like this.
There's a lot of us
that have that same mentality."
-I read the book and then
I also got the audio book,
by the way.
And who helped you
with the book as well?
-My agent, my business partner
and my coauthor, Shari Wenk.
-Shari Wenk, who I met
backstage. She's fantastic.
-She is fantastic. She's one
of the reasons I'm here, folks.
Give it up for her,
will you, please?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She really is great.
And if you like the book,
you get the audio book
and it's extra stuff and you
guys having conversations
and then -- so there's
little bonus stuff.
But I did that as well.
And whoever you got
to read the audio book,
by the way, was fantastic.
And his voice is
very intimidating.
And I was like, "Wow, this was
really great." I loved it.
Can we talk a little bit
about Kobe Bryant?
-Yes, we can.
-Here's, you, no mustache,
with Kobe.
-Yes. A suit that didn't fit.
But back then that was --
well, maybe wasn't a style
but that back then
that's what I wore.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-What can we say about Kobe,
his style of training?
-I mean, he's just
the definition of winning, man.
It was unbelievable.
You know, when you ask
individuals -- It was funny.
I asked all my clients,
including him.
I said, "Listen,
describe winning in one word."
And, you know, you get a lot
of individuals that tell you,
you know, it's joyful,
it's happiness, it's fun.
It's all these other things.
But the true winners,
that's the end of winning.
That's at the end of winning.
But when you have
to really describe winning,
what it really means
and what it takes,
it's, you know,
it's unapologetic,
it's dirty, it's nasty.
If you go through
all those things,
then you get to the joy part
and then you get to the end.
But it's all the obstacles
in between.
It's about the grind and knowing
you're grinding for a purpose.
You know, individuals
always say, "Listen,
yeah,
I'm grinding, I'm grinding."
Everybody said, "Man,
I'm grinding for success.
I'm grinding for this."
Well, if you take
two pieces of object
and you just grind them
together, what happens?
It turns into dust.
-Yeah.
-But when you see people
do ice sculptures
or you see clay or art
or, you know,
if we have any
artistic individuals out here,
they grind away
the unessentials
to form what they need,
what that piece
is going to look like.
And that's what Kobe did.
That's what Kobe did.
That's what Michael did.
That's what Dwyane did.
That's what
all these individuals do,
is they grind away
the unessentials
so they can have this sculpture
of what winning
looks like for them,
and it looks different
for each individual.
As slight as it may be,
it's different.
-Yeah.
-Just a little bit different.
-I can't even tell you.
This is exactly what you read.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This book has helped
a lot of people,
and you were nice enough
to bring a copy of "W1nning"
for everyone
in our audience tonight.
Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I knew you'd be great.
Come on.
Thank you so much
for coming to see me.
Come back. Please.
-I promise. Anytime.
-Thank you.
-Tim Grover. Check out his book
"W1nning,"
which is available everywhere.